ja hallo mein name ist georg gratis ich
befinde mich hier im sanitätszentrum süd
bin ein militärischen zusammen heißt
sogar ein gericht im rahmen einer
vorbereitungs ausbildung zu rb 22 im
zivilen leben bin ich als eines besitzt
intensivmediziner und motors am lkh uni
klinikum tätig unsere inhalte die wir
hier im rahmen der vorbereitung machen
sind spezifische trainings von allen
eingereichten teilen und aktiven kader
mitglieder die sich im lager von
stationsbetrieb
durchführen lassen wir haben
stationsbetrieb mit einer station zur
bauma simulation wo das ist kern am ziel
ist dass die teilnehmerinnen wieder
zusammengeschaltet werden wir haben wir
die struktur wird ein taucher versorger
das halte alle teile eine gemeinsame
basis finden um wirklich schlucken wird
zielgerichtet vor präsenten aus
europäischer sicht zu versorgen eine
weitere station ist eine der
internistische strategische durch
untersuchung nach einem speziellen thema
das die cd schema nennen so dass auch
die teilung und teile machen
strukturiert gemeinsam auf einen nenner
gebracht werden
auf den penis
damit wir auch
jetzt auch die wintersonne und auch
freundlichen gesandt um kinder versorgen
können gibt es auch eine spezielle
station wo kinder notfälle simuliert
werden wo alle teilnehmerinnen und
teilnehmer
durchstrukturiert ausgebildete trainer
durch kinder szenarien durchgeführt
werden wo sie sich dann auch einmal ganz
konzentriert auf alle bedürfnisse des
kindlichen not vorbildes
vorbereiten können zwei weitere
stationen bilden dann noch den abschluss
vertraut machen mit dem gerät das dann
im einzel zusammen zur verwendung ist
und spezifische einzel fertigkeiten
biete assistenzleistungen zu welche
produktionen am monitor
assistenzleistungen pd anlage 12 kanal
ekg unter wert dergleichen mehr das sind
die vorbereitungsmaßnahmen die wir im
rahmen der ersten beiden übungstage hier
abrutschen